let's go next to our caller from the 254
area code who's calling today from 254
hi david this is leon from austin hey
leon
great show hey listen i have uh several
questions but i had to pick
one and maybe the other ones or two
other ones for another show
and it's about stephen miller and the
whole
issue and fiasco about uh what is going
on with the stephen miller and the white
nationalist
yeah and um i do i do however have an
insight on the person who asked you how
many countries
could potentially trump with meddling
with
you know he's uh russia now for hating
ukraine is because they
spoke badly about him they don't like
him
and so if we're going to count all the
countries that don't like him
for example
you know it's possible england england
may have interfered with elections as
well
but i think the caller was asking where
trump is interfering not if england
interfered but if trump is interfering
in england right i think
um well uh according to stephen miller
this is a more serious
and very delicate issue um
this allegations about his interaction
and his uh
fanatism for white nationalism has been
brought up to him before
yes and his defense was actually going
to an immediate attack
saying that how dare you do that i'm a
jew and my family survived holocaust
right
and blah blah blah and many people
actually were afraid of bringing this up
in the past because of that issue
in that answer that he had that line
that he used
now um there said the holocaust is
something very horrible
that indeed happened and many jews fled
during and survivors after
and most of them came to
america and you know when i say america
i'm talking about the continent
in general and with
nothing absolutely nothing
yeah i mean it's like it's like my
family that went from uh from eastern
europe to argentina with nothing
yeah however there is a few and luckily
a few
that are actually for unknown reasons
and that has been explored
er escape quoted and quoted
but actually with a lot of money and
there have been investigations and done
by groups that
also you know there were some jews at
times so leon
let me put a pause in the direction
you're going because i don't but
i i don't i'm not saying you're going to
do this but you may be about to go in a
very very ugly direction but let me tell
you this
jews are for the most part very liberal
they have been on the forefront of the
civil rights movement in the united
states and in other places
they are widely targets of white
nationalism
but there are also people of any group
regardless of their
identity jews included like stephen
miller
who are absolutely outrageous
reactionaries
and the fact that if they attack
identity politics which they do
they shouldn't be at the same time be
able to hide behind their identity as
stephen miller has sometimes tried to do
i think that's how i would
uh contextualize it
yeah i mean and i totally agreed i mean
the religion has nothing to do with
those uh extreme idealism yes
that you can uh profess it but nobody
seemed to be
able to put it together and you know put
him in his place
right to answer that uh well listen leon
i appreciate
the question where are you from
originally where are you from originally
my friend
where i'm originally from yeah i was
born in argentina actually but uh
you know i suspected that from your
accent i have i am regularly around
people from argentina who speak english
and i am not surprised to hear you say
that from buenos aires or somewhere else
yeah buenos aires oh yeah but i i
actually
left buenos aires when i was five years
old so did that time he moved to peru
oh okay and uh where i spent quite a bit
of time there
very nice all right leon i appreciate
the phone call maybe the first uh fellow
argentinian that is called in
mucha gracias
okay all right we'll talk to you very
very soon we will mark him uh
very very high in the call scoring
system of course